[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and welcome to
your first look and hands on with the
galaxy s 21
ultra so right off the top of the year
samsung's coming out swinging now i also
have a video about the s21 and s21 plus
dropping at the same time here so
that'll be the first link below the like
button check it out if you're interested
but this is the big dog so we kind of
know what to expect at this point from
samsung's new ultra high end phones
right so s21 ultra will start at 1200
bucks
so it should be the best of what they
can offer but just to look back for a
second at s20 ultra this phone last year
was
kind of a whiff i mean it still did have
a lot of the high end ultra
numbers that you look for but because of
the focus issues with the camera it was
just never something you quite
recommended it got passed on a lot for
the money so the s21 ultra looks to get
them back to the best of everything
world with a lot of next-gen parts and
pieces now right off the bat first thing
you notice is the biggest change which
is they've packed everything in this new
design so we might as well just start
with that so i got to handle these in
the matte black and this sort of silver
color so it looks just like the leaks
and the rumors we're expecting and i
think i like it now i don't know if i
love it i'm still on the train that sort
of a horizontal camera bump like nexus
6p was actually kind of peak but the
more i look at this contour cut design
the more futuristic it looks to me it
kind of looks like someone was making a
thicker phone with the huge cameras and
then just melted it down to a thinner
body for the rest of the phone it's kind
of hard to explain it basically it looks
like harvey dent like two face but on
the smaller models it actually has a
cool color contrast model with the side
rails but i'll talk more about that in
that video on the ultra it's all matte
across the entire back which i love and
then shiny on the sides so speaking of
those cameras we've got four here on the
back of the ultra it's a new second gen
108 megapixel main camera with ois at f
1.8 very curious to see how that'll
shoot then you've got a 12 megapixel
ultrawide which should be pretty sweet
at 120 degrees and then
two telephoto cameras you've got two a
3x telephoto and a 10x periscope lens so
this is an interesting zoom situation i
was playing with the phone trying to
imagine why they would do it like this i
i think samsung's probably done the math
on well most people either zoom in a
little bit or like all the way
and so i guess if they're just getting a
3x
and then the 10x will facilitate the
space zoom that goes really far my
curiosity is how will it do in between
3x and 10x
we'll have to see but if you go in the
camera app it looks very familiar it's
the samsung stuff all these zoom buttons
are still here but now you can see you
can go all the way from that 3x to 10x
and it's doing digital zoom in between
those two numbers then from 10x on it's
coming from the periscope lens and space
zoom is still here so you can go all the
way to 100 on the ultra and it's right
off the bat actually looking much more
stable than the last gen which is
actually pretty nice there's also some
improvements to the higher end modes
like a director's view for more control
over live switching between the cameras
and recording from multiple cameras at
once and there's also multi-device
recording from both the phone's mics and
your headphone mics at the same time and
then improved single take mode so cool
stuff here we all know the ultra and
samsung's lineup is supposed to have the
top of the line cameras and this is the
best they can offer and you can you can
even see the laser autofocus here so i'm
almost surprised i didn't toss in a
macro camera to sort of fill up the
space and make an even grid but hey it's
a periscope lens taking up that space
instead begging to be tested so yeah
lots of new camera parts it'll be
interesting to see how these perform
definitely make sure you subscribe to
the channel if you haven't already to be
among the first to see the review when
it comes out we can test these things
but enough about the back of the phone
let's talk about the front so it's a big
phone of course it's the ultra and that
allows for a huge 6.8 inch quad hd oled
display and this time it's quad hd
at 120 hertz so you can see here in the
settings it's at the 1440p resolution
and motion smoothness is also set to
adaptive up to 120 hertz so that's sweet
but also this new adaptive refresh rate
on the ultra is new and it'll
automatically constantly be switching
all the way up and down between 10 hertz
and 120 hertz so that should help save a
lot of battery in this adaptive mode
it'll be really interesting to test to
see how responsive it is and to see how
much battery it saves so you imagine
when you're not really doing anything on
the display nothing's moving it
throttles all the way down to 10 hertz
i'm curious if that can
bring it to the same battery life or
close to the regular 60 hertz mode
i'm not too worried about overall
battery life the phone does still have a
5 000 milliamp hour battery so uh not
concerned about being bad i'm just more
curious if it can be amazing i also love
that the display is nearly flat it is
slightly rounded at the very edges but
not nearly as much as i've seen it in
other phones which makes me happy
and there is the small cutout at the top
for the ridiculous 40 megapixel selfie
camera and they also dropped qualcomm's
new much larger and hopefully faster in
display fingerprint sensor back there
it's 1.77 times larger than the last gen
and i'm hoping less finicky too and the
display's max brightness is now up to 25
percent brighter up to 1500 nits and
there's a new ai based blue light shield
option for better viewing comfort if
you're into that but yeah everything
else you're looking at here is right in
line with what you'd expect from the
2021 samsung flagship great build
quality it's ip68 water resistant the
newest internals of course with the five
nanometer snapdragon triple eight in
this region it'll be the five nanometer
exynos chip in other regions which will
be interesting again to test to see how
it fares with battery
15 watt wireless charging there's
reverse wireless charging too great
buttons tiny bezels the whole thing one
interesting spec though that is missing
there is no expandable storage anymore
so the micro sd card
is basically going extinct now samsung
was some of the last ones to do in their
flagships so there are only three specs
for total storage on this phone 128 256
or 512 gigs and then so unlike the
smaller s21 and s21 plus there's
different amounts of ram on these
versions so those all will have eight
gigs of ram on the ultra you start at 12
gigs of ram for the 128 and 256 and if
you go with the tip top half a terabyte
max spec that'll have 16 gigs of ram
so your trading your expandable storage
for a lot of ram i guess also speaking
of things that are gone no headphones or
charger in the box confirmed like i've
warned you this is gonna start happening
very quickly across the industry iphone
12 was a huge domino to fall so now
don't expect a power brick and a
flagship phone from here on out but
last thing let's talk about the s pen
it was added to the s21 ultra s pen
support now okay a lot of people saw
this
in the rumors leading up to this and
thought oh that probably means the
galaxy note is on its way out maybe
they'll kill it soon
i don't think so
i when i this is just coming from my
like hour of playing with the phone the
stylus on the s21 ultra feels like a
very optional
add-on
accessory
where on the galaxy note well it's still
an integral part of the note experience
and it's just they're in very different
worlds so first of all like i said it's
an optional 40 accessory so if you want
to buy an s pen for your s21 ultra it'll
cost you and then it's actually
compatible with other s pens of the past
so if you have one already you can carry
that too but the whole experience is
passive so the whole low latency writing
and drawing experience is all the same
but there's no bluetooth or gesture
controls like you would have on the note
and then of course there's a whole how
do you carry it question since there's
no silo built into the phone so that's
another optional accessory so you can
get a stylus and a case for now 70 extra
dollars and the phone sort of just
clicks into this rubber slot in the side
of the case which is fine i guess but
it's it's definitely a very optional
accessory and so if you're gonna go
through all of that and spend extra
money to to have a stylus on your
high-end samsung phone i feel like the
obvious choice is to
buy a note where it slots in
perfectly and neatly every time charges
has the active experience has more
features and of course there will be a
note 21 ultra i guess it's not an of
course thing i'm predicting there will
be a note 21 ultra that people wanting a
stylish consider later this year so i
don't think the note's going anywhere
but that's basically it for the new s21
ultra what do you think is this enough
of a redemption i mean you get the huge
numbers again you get a lot of next-gen
pieces it seems to be going in the right
direction there is of course the s21 and
s21 plus launching alongside it on
january 29th but if you're gonna spend
the big bucks this is what you're gonna
get and they've also launched smart tags
and galaxy buds pro so samsung's clearly
popping off right at the beginning of
the year but let me know what you think
is this the one you guys would pick or
would you go for one of the other s21
models let me know thanks for watching
i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]